good afternoon councilors staff members
of the public welcome along to this uh
hearings Committee of the community
well-being committee to hear about the
reclassification of Queens
part
uh I have apologies
from councilors SOA and
St simply like to move that they are
accepted Evelyn and Ria thank you put
that all in favor I against
carried councilors and Bob uh you're all
aware of the submissions process just as
a um
as a method of comfort the full
committee meeting that that follows this
which is when uh decisions are likely to
made be made will be in public and
despite the fact there are
recommendations that sit in there that
have come from staff they're a
placeholder okay so you will absolutely
determine on each of the matters
yourselves which isn't necessarily based
on on what the staff's in there so um
please bear that in mind and Bob I hope
you take some some comfort in that
uh Bob welcome along you're speaking on
behalf of uh two submitters yourself and
also Chris Henderson and you're speaking
to Chris's submission first corre Bob
the time is yours welcome thank
you all counselor Darren no Noby um
Council of Staff media representatives
in the public thank you for the
opportunity D Bob Simpson and Chris
henerson has asked me to apologize for
her not being here and asked me to speak
on her submission opposed to the project
1225 Queens Park
reclassification and asks the council
not to demolish the
permit so you've got three pages so I'll
speak to Chris's first then I'll speak
to mine then I've got some guidelines
and I think you've got those three
sheets so Chris is the chair of the
friends of the South Museum and art
gallery now the Chicago city council has
decided to separate the museum and art
gallery functions Chris and I think this
is a
mistake we believe the museum and art
gallery should remain
together and they should be in the inner
city over the years our community has
invested in the inner city and the
museum and art gallery will enhance the
center because it as an attraction for
both local people and for
visitors Chris would like to to
see existing inner city buildings used
for the museum and art
gallery Chris and I suggest the pyramid
could be upgraded altered and extended
to accommodate many activities and a
planetarium it could include a calf on
the north of the building opening onto
an outdoor seating area and onto Queens
Park it could include changing rooms
lock and showers for locals and visitors
so they can enjoy outdoor
recreation it could include display
areas and workplaces for artists and
Crafts
People some areas could become a
community and education Hub and some
could be saved for sto could be used for
storage could include on the first floor
spaces with dormal Windows and balconies
to open the building up to the Views and
to provide social spaces and meeting
rooms
a proposal to retain the pyramid would
save on demolition costs and reduce the
volume of materials going to
landfill we understand the argument it
is too late to pause project
1225 the ICC have not sorted the Queens
Park site out which is why we're here
and we believe the museum and art
gallery should be in the Inner
City in in our opinion a modified
pyramid building could again become a
much loved Community
Asset the research which has been done
for the project 1225 and the lessons
which have been learned can be used in
the design of inner city museum and art
gallery Chris and I think that in theago
city council will get credit for Having
the courage to pause and have a cup of
tea and consider the bigger
picture this big picture includes the
the ReUse of the pyramid in Queens Park
and improving inner city by having the
museum and art gallery where more people
can enjoy
it that's my first bit under Chris's
section you have any
questions councilors questions and they
must be
questions
Evelyn it's through you Mr chov um
um I appreciate the sentiments that are
in there but where in you appreciate
that I appreciate the sentiments that
are expressed but where in there is the
addressing of the issue of the
reclassification of the land well we're
opposed which is why we're opposed to
that because um we think it should
remain for recreational
use so that's actually in the submission
that you've got in that is in the
papers so if I
can PR you that the position is that the
re classification is not needed because
you believe it should be Rel the pro
project could be relocated to a CBD
location so say it
again so if I were to pry Bob your
position or the position of Chris and
the friends is that no no sorry this
isn't the friends but Chris is the chair
of the friends right my apologies thanks
for the correction and Chris's position
is that the reclassification is not
needed because the project should take
place within the
CBD Yeah
well yeah is there the position
um
uh
yes I mean there's a lot of other
information that you presented around it
but I'm just trying to get to the the
crack yes it's not really clear to me
anyway that your principally opposed to
the reclassification on the basis that
it should be used for recreation
everything that has been discussed has
been about so this isn't heading in the
direction of a question is it no you're
just clarifying yeah yeah thank you
thank you any other
questions no okay Bob if you want to
move on to your submission please
right
um so I'm starting mine with the
question of taking a pause and having a
cup of tea for the
council Quin Park is a
wonderful Community amenity and is
enjoyed by thousands of people the South
Museum and art gallery in the pyramid
was a well-used building from its
opening in
1990 until it was suddenly closed in
April
2018 because the council was advised it
was earthquake
prone our community was shocked at
losing this asset and this well-loved
amenity over the years many people
visited the building seeking information
excitement and fellowship the smag staff
shared their knowledge with visitors
young and old the CF was a popular place
and the shop provided good products
often Southland
Source in
1988 2 and a half years before the
pyramid was opened the New Zealand Prime
Minister David longy called for
everybody to take a pause and have a cup
of tea to slow down the romics band
wagon of Rob rapid
change that's where my the reference the
cup of tea comes
from those of you are I'm telling you
cuz that's what happened way back then
and some of you hadn't me da
anyway the inago city council is now
pushing ahead with several projects
today I ask you to take a pause and have
that cup of tea then you should have a
brief
holiday and in 2014 you can reconsider
your
priorities if the council pauses and
makes better decisions we'll all
benefit the ICC preferred option to
demolish the perid of sorry the icc's
preferred option is to demolish the per
pyramid my preferred option is to retain
the building and transform it to become
a community hub for many different user
groups which I addressed in my
previous discussion on cross's
paper a good part of the success of the
sou Museum and art gallery and the
Eastern souland Art Gallery in associate
activities is the combined Museum and
art the combined Museum and artistic
activities for some reason the recent
ICC proposals have the museum and art
facilities activities separated so
basically I'm arguing against
that
um my recommendations is to combine the
museum and art gallery and to locate
them in the inner city where more people
can enjoy them and they can enhance the
inner
city the large h&j Smith sites are now
vacant and I recommend the inago city
council buy them and consider the best
long-term uses for the
sites here are some suggestions for the
a H andj Smith
sites build a staged Southern Museum and
art gallery
complex the council has a combined
budget of about $80 million for arts and
creativity and
smack this budget could be used for
buildings on these
sites build some conference and meeting
rooms and office spaces for the three
local
authorities develop a good Public Square
for celebrations for performances and
for
protests provide some parking for cars
and bikes for staff and the
community design buildings with which
could be staged and changed and
expanded because about the only thing we
can be sure about is things will
change
conclusions at a recent council meeting
about walking the place in E Street West
the council was advised when they are
recommending changes to have an
alternative to a place the things which
they like which are likely to be
removed Shifting the southern music Muse
an art gallery from Queens Park will
upset some
people if the council promotes feasible
options the community is more likely to
accept
them moving on to my final paper that
you've got I
think guidelines to assist
clients complete successful
projects plan to do things well and
provide positive leadership and clear
Communications except there will be
Chang and acknowledge mistakes and
correct
them consider the big picture including
the context and the longer
term define the challenges
problems the challenges SL problems is
important to establish the needs and to
Define them
clearly provide realistic cost budgets
and reasonable time
frames involve people with good local
knowledge and people with the
appropriate skills of approach
you under promise and overd
deliver then the community will be
happy that's the end of my formal
bit thanks Bob what do you envisage the
community Hub you've
suggested could be
useful well there are lots of artists
in Media accommodation in attics and and
around the town and so I mentioned
displays and workshops for them but the
community H it's very difficult to find
meeting spaces you get a meeting space
in a library when you've got strange
hours
um we need more Community Building more
more Community spaces in my view and on
the first floor in that building if you
put some dormal windows up so you can
actually look out rather than be in
closed by the building you've actually
got good views and good light and good
windows and I think those activities
could happen
there and that's in a
refurbished P pyramid
Y and the activities Museum and art
gallery activities of oning are keep
together I don't I don't I believe that
they're better off in town and I've
argued those AR that argument before
often just for the AR I mean I've been
involved with the smag a long time and
it's been all sorts of Endeavors to
increase the size of it as you know um
and one of the things was to shift the
art but into town now we've actually got
the first size time we've actually had a
decent sized
budget um and I think we've got an
amazing opportunity with the Smith site
and I think that now is a good time to
take advantage of that what do you
estimate the costs would be around
dealing with the earthquake Quake prone
part of the Smith
site um I think the Smith site
earthquake prone stuff will get solved
by
demolition I'm not suggest I mean I
mentioned that Chris would like to reuse
the building I'm not in that camp I'm
a a new building person I think the new
building should be designed so it can be
expanded I mean I mentioned
staged I mean I think the size the
current proposed that 4,000 meters is
large um
and there are numerous other problems I
think with the design of
the um current
proposal um Queens
Park don't mention those if you want but
no I'm just pray seeing what you you
you've got on your submission thanks Bob
Tom Bob your submission refers to
the fact that the pyramid was closed
because of the earthquake risk but I
think you'll be aware that since then we
become aware of the fact that it's also
fire risk um and that the issues around
Insurance are actually fire risk
correcting you Tom the fire risk was
notified first earthquake bur risk came
second okay um whichever order but Bob I
mean the retention of the pyramid you
must be aware of that fire risk issue
what would be your respon to that well I
know there are different opinions on
that as I understand it the building is
sprink is that true say again SC
sprinklers yes sprink um so I don't
think that's serious issue I I think
there's been a serious number of myths
around about that building I didn't say
it was earthquake CR I was very careful
I said the council got advice that it
was the hours worth of disc discussion
suggest that
there's conflicting views about the
wisdom of
that um and so it was closed suddenly
you know with 4 days notice and still
hasn't fallen down and other museums
around the place that had greater risks
are still open like
G
so that's another whole sad story but
um
I I
think Darren asked for an estimate
um and and my question so I could could
raise I sort of put it back here
um
uh somewhere I
did
um I think you might find now that
there's some at that time there'd been
no serious um
whatever they call that ground testing
stuff is
um Geotech geot be no serious Geotech
stuff I supervised a modest thing on the
side and the assumptions that were made
I think by Engineers out of the United
States who did the report um assumed it
was worse than it actually is and so I
think you probably now got different
results although those haven't been
published um but I assume there's been
some testing done Geotech um I assume
theyve done a while ago but then I think
so saw something recently with your
advertising to do so it's a bit
confusing how things get done around
here but I think the
building the first part of the building
was built in 1940
after things got to be sensible after
the earthquakes in in napia and the
additions after that the sensible the
pyramid shape itself with a steel frame
over the whole lot of that is remarkably
stable um structure and you can't
actually get something more stable than
that and the fact that it got a sticker
on it as a higher Zone thing is hard
Justified but
anyway okay thank
you thank
you R thank you thank you for your
submission um I know that you are a very
well
um experienced architect and a lot of
the history that you provided to this
Council has been pretty much pit perpect
I want to ask one of the questions of
you that you've asked of us can you
accept there will be changes and
acknowledge the mistakes that have been
made and that the council can correct
them again I want to ask you the
question that you've asked of us can you
accept there will be changes and
acknowledge mistakes that the council
have made and that we can treat
them well I I'm asking you to do that
are you asking me to my mistake would
you accept that that question you're
asking of us I'm asking would you accept
that back if I asked you the same
question whether I made mistakes no what
I'm saying
is the information that you provided
yeah has been very substantial to the
permid museum yes that you put a a piece
in here that it was closed suddenly
because it was earthquake PR it was
claimed to be correct of your own
submission and you're asking the council
um will we accept that there will be
changes and acknowledge mistakes and
correct them and what I'm asking you is
the same
question as a submitter and as a very
well um experienced architect inago
you've got the history Pitch Perfect of
a lot of what the council does and from
your submission I can see that you don't
want change or you consider that there
is a better option out there for the
pyramid or a gallery art gallery or
Museum that you're offering complete
change for it to be put into the sorry
councelor you're really getting off
track well I guess it doesn't ask
question well sorry Mr Simpson asked the
question of of council anyway so I I
think the question fairly exists he's
asked it of us um
I I'd also query the use of the term
Pitch
Perfect what' you say sorry the comment
was to the counselor what' you say I
said I queried her use of the term Pitch
Perfect he
know
um my
previous Endeavors to get the art
gallery in town with just the art
gallery not the museum because at that
stage those stages when I was promoting
that and that included buying 42 T
Street which I actually took an option
on to shift out gaing the town was to
take press off the museum building um
but so I've changed and at a later
date had an interview and photographs
taken
to put the thing
into the Old Farmers building but my
change is I now think that the art
gallery and Museum should remain
combined which I mean when I read those
things in the past Russell Beck used to
give me a hard time because he believed
that
having them combined was important
thanks Bob so your answer to R's
question is clearly yes you believe you
can change because you've changed your
position around the separation of Art
and Museum thank you
thanks M
Clark I'm sorry for being late I had ENT
matter um two years ago this Council um
fac the issue of uh refurbishing the
pyramid or looking at an alternative and
so they voted just about unanimously to
look at the alternative so the pyramid
issue in my view is gone uh a majority
of our rate PES have said they want any
new Museum to be located at Queens Park
they don't want us to bring it into the
inner city so we're Bound by that I
guess um and at the time two years ago
we made a uh uh a decision on Council to
separate art and history which is the
museum concept away from each other that
art was better delivered in other areas
of the city other than in the museum um
and certainly my assessment of most
large cities in New Zealand and
certainly those in Australia as they
have separate facilities both for art
and for the museum they don't mix the
two so the question I've got for you I
guess is the submissions today about
whether or not you believe that Council
should change the designation on the
tennis courts area so that we can expand
the proposed uh build of the new Museum
further to
the west west and so I'd like to give
you on that because I don't think well
certainly from my perspective I'm not
here to debate what we've historically
um agreed on looking at other options
and we're too far down the track um and
you'll know at the time I was opposed to
the museum being closed and I was also
oos we can just stick to the question to
the alternative so I'm just laying out
the land that I just would like you to
tell us what you think about the issue
of the change of designation for that
portion of the land so we can build on
it and whether you're opposed to that or
not I am I very clearly said that and
Chris says that and we think it should
remain recreational land so you can play
tennis there or do other things on it Y
and you should convert the pyramid
building or additions to the permit so
that people who want to do recreation in
Queens Park and have showers get changed
have lockers and use it as Recreation I
mean it's actually unusual to have got
permission to build the museum in the
first place
on that Reserve Land so I think I look
through the papers but know your next
180 Pages quite a lot of that saying I
don't really want to step through that
um is saying don't then
don't so I've got a couple so the answer
is I think that land should stay for
recreation and we should recognize that
changes to the pyramid can actually make
the build
much better for its relationship with
the park and for outdoor recreation
which is the function of the current
tennis court Reserve Land status and I
think it should remain for that reason
me Clark uh just a couple of other quick
questions um do you know who the current
users of the building on the 10th courts
are I read that someone going to submit
after this
um
so yes but so what well okay I guess
I'll got a couple follow-up questions to
that um it's a cultural group that has
said that they're prepared to move
elsewhere because they they see the
benefit of the expanded Museum when was
the last time you saw tennis played on
the courts oh probably about a year ago
yeah it it's fair to say that it's very
very rare isn't it
well it's real but that's not to say it
doesn't happen and there was a time when
people used to come to our house to get
the keys to use the court um sort of a
longterm person who knows that but
there's no reason why we can't encourage
people during their break times and when
people have more flexible hours to play
tennis at
lunchtime yeah and and to do other
things where they get a sweat up and
want to have a shower and those things
can happen on or adjacent to the current
pyramid and then it's a sensible
recreation facility just
sorry just one you've gone to quite a
lot of trouble to improve the things in
town and the things that have changed
dramatically I mean I I started making
list it was just too great but in the
last 10 years the changes include the
council selling the land becamea um the
development of um the inner city block
deal which could do with more patronage
by visitors who visit museums and art
galleries
and the same with the people in
lunchtime who work in the inner city we
actually need to improve the density of
activity in the inner city and this is
an opportunity if you take a bit of a
break and recognize that
your um discussions two years ago didn't
get much serious in input impact because
I mean I didn't even notice it was going
on I mean I was trying to hibernate I
have to say but um you've managed to
shake me out of
my
retirement from making public comment
you helped with that with your attitude
to something
else M CL you have one last question uh
just as a a statement for for Bob thing
and and a question to run into it
um um I think 2021 from recollection
I'll be corrected if it's 22 I think
it's 2021 we did a survey um with their
community and it involved about a th000
people so some were by uh email some
were by cold calling people quite an
extensive Community inter
interface I think something like about
90% of the people that we engaged with
said they didn't want um a museum
sitting right in the middle of the city
for engagement of people that worked in
the city they said they wanted the
museum to be retained at Queens Park as
part of an experience of going to Queens
Park Park as well um so um would be
remiss not to do things one last issue I
have is that did you make a submission
um two years ago when we were
considering the the new um museum at the
park no but um you did say at a meeting
that I was out here rela recently y that
the people that make a noise are the
people who are upset and aren't
necessarily the majority at all you're
saying that with regard to walking the
place
well I think that's that's another
argument except it's another argument
but I mean I mean to your credit I mean
we've got four four submitters I think
or five submitters today on on this
piece of land if I use the argument that
you just thrown back to me I'd ignored
the lotel wouldn't I you was so we're
getting into debate lot of them wouldn't
I have we got any more questions I don't
think you had an
option any other questions M Clark no
thank you councelor c um thank you Mr Mr
chair um the mayor actually took the
words out of my mouth so thank you for
that any other questions
councilors okay just to to pry again the
basis of the submission Bob is that you
are against the reclassification because
you believe the current site by the
museum could be reused as a community
Hub and that the museum and art gallery
functions should be kept together should
be within the CBD and therefore not
require um the reclassification of land
correct and that the current pyramid
building with some alterations and
additions and a better
roof is has the potential for a major
Improvement for um many people that use
and could use Queens
Park thank you no f the
questions thanks again Bob appreciate
you coming
in P welcome Along come up take a
seat share with us who your friend is
yes um Amanda Pon we're both members of
heres thank you welcome
Amanda
[Music]
right shall I just start please do okay
um I've been a member of Heritage roses
souland for about 30 years and I'm
making this submission on behalf of our
club during that time I've often looked
at the Jesse CER Rose Garden for
information about a particular Rose or
even just to admire the many roses that
won't fit into my garden many many
people do the same thing we value the
collection and see it as a source of
inspiration for our own Gardens and
something the public can enjoy at no
cost to them you have information flyer
in front of you that has been available
from Parks and reserves for several
years looks like
that this is an excellent thing and
provides all the background information
on how the garden and surrounds came
about the garden was officially opened
in December 198 by The Honorable Helen
Clark who was deputy prime minister at
that time the Jesse cter Garden has
several rare roses that are no longer
available in Commerce and are possibly
the only specimens in New Zealand on
public display for this reason alone
they need to be protected and cared for
in recent years the garden has suffered
a bit for various reasons and is not
currently as Lush as it was 10 or 12
years ago probably the most significant
reason for the decline is of water roses
need regular deep watering to maintain
their health and good appearance We
Believe construction of the museum and
Landscaping of the surrounds is an ideal
opportunity to get irrigation into the
Garden in recent time several roses have
died and there are gaps in some beds
staff do the best they can but without
adequate water available it is
impossible to overcome the problem of
dry
Summers we also ask that the brick wall
on the south side of the garden be
retained the garden is of English design
and a wall along the clim with which
climbing roses grow is often a feature
of that style the wall provides shelter
and reflective warmth for the
plantings Public Gardens are the best
place for many roses because that is
where everyone locals as well as
visitors can come and see them I've no
doubt that some of you have never been
to the Jesse CER Garden I urge you to
take your lunch time time sandwich and
go and sit in the garden there are seats
and take in your surrounds it's very
calming thanks Pat so bearing in mind
that the hydration of the Roses isn't
really part of what we're considering I
can assure you that our senior Park
staff are here hand have heard what you
said can I just confirm what is the
position then of Heritage roses South
and on the reclassification are you
supportive of it provided there is no
disruption to the Jesse called The
Garden the roses and the walls yes yes
no problem with the reification it's
just that this is the opportunity when
building is there and undergoing you
know there'll be um Landscaping no doubt
about that's the opportunity to get a
ration into the into the garden good
point Thank You counselors any
questions
Evelyn yes thank you Mr chair um look I
know it's also not to do with the
reserve status which is really what the
hearing is about but you have mentioned
the brick wall
so have you any feelings about more
transition from the museum to the
gardens through that brick wall because
that's part of the reason for extending
the um site as well when I looked at the
diagram it doesn't have any kind I mean
the brick wers there in that diagram
there brick wers there yes sign know
that it's like from the museum side it
will look out onto the back of the brick
wall may be an archway on either end at
either end would be um an access into
the garden but not get rid of the brick
wall all together no I think thank you
because I take your point um I love
growing roses I'm not very good at it
but um I do understand about the um
importance of the War but I do also know
that there has been conversation and
that's part of the reason for um
extending the site is to make the
transition from one place to the other
so I have heard I haven't seen any plans
but we we sort of have heard that but
maybe a compromise you know a couple of
arway like this is the wall cway there
and there thank you for your
clarification I appreciate it I too suck
at growing roses but I love enjoying the
work of other
people Ria thank you very much I just
wanted to let you know that I spent we
at Garden High School weding
it the heart sure it wasn't
detention
probably but I'm interested um to hear
that um you wouldn't if I he you right
you wouldn't be opposed to some sections
of that world been taken away to let
thorough through happen um and you've
mentioned too like um about the special
roses that are not known or growing
anywhere else in the world
um not the
world New Zealand thought we were more
special um but if they were in areas do
you know where are they in areas along
that brick wall for con no no so if we
had to re um establish some of those
Roses in order to protect them say we
pastar of the wall how well would those
Roses be up to bounce back with proper
um
nourishment and re none of the r some
referring to are along the brick wall
none of them the small Bush roses and
the brick wall is um climbers and some
perennials isn't it car Carolyn know um
yeah but there is I mean there's a
couple of roses on that brickboard that
I've referred to in the submission and
they're absolutely magnificent they
really really are and it would be a
shame to um affect them but nevertheless
they're not rare and they could be
reestablished you know that kind of
thing but but it's just that when
they're out they're absolutely
fabulous thank you Alex oh that's
okay other
questions if there are none thank you
for taking the time to log your
submission and for coming in this
afternoon thank you for listening thank
you they beautiful roses I there do go
and have a sit
down y this is a good time of the year
thanks councilors I'm just going to
adjourn uh briefly and pause because
we're still waiting for uh a submitter
to appear on zoom and uh there are a few
people who've come along in support of
that submission as well oh now they're
just joining now look at that
magic so we're just loading the uh
presentation
uh Jay are your group speaking to this
submission as as as
well do you want to come up and take a
seat so felic is it yes this and
Janine and
Jay
and on
Zoom bya welcome
along who's leading oh we still leading
the presentation or is it up excellent
who's leading
it let
see please the time is yours welcome
hello everybody and um thank you for
willing to see us today my name is
felici you um chai and chenine and
Via we are representing uh we are here
on behalf of um CL Mal
um
Mar CL my the name is come from the
Bible uh Matthew
5:41 this mean my go extra mile to help
help someone and that's what our group
is all about is helping other
people and uh our
group uh V is the president of the uh
the
group and um this group
here we
uh if Christmas time we go and um play
music for the at the rest home for old
people we do um try to help out the the
community so today why Le is um
just going to try to explain why we here
today but um
yeah thank you thank you very
much the time is
yours we do have a presentation than
you the time and
um won't be long I'm in Oakland someone
in Old pass away and I sorry for that
and
um yeah is what Felicia say that's our
main thing is it go for extra extra mou
not only the tong but no the way the
community at s and um and Mai as well
join us but what I'm coming from is um
the um because of the the the
museum project is so you have to um
no we be facing now is from
110 um uh Victoria a Avenue is the the
tennis court um perian but we understand
that the the ten um tennis court going
to be go away soon or later um we
definitely support the
museum the museum is is is a white
Community but
what I'm I'm coming from is the find
find some place for us to
move before before before we um make was
the council is um telling us to to um
know find somewhere to
go I think that that that that one is
not
on we have to work together to find a
place for us um
I know mightbe um J and Felicia add
something up that's the really reason of
we we want new Fells to hear they say
that I find a place so we can move move
to um continue on what we
doing um like the sport the community
and um and um some of the um workers
from um
overseas
from is with us but um we find a place
is we call it we call this this place is
is m h m Community H is it's a place for
us to go and spend the time in um doing
what we doing now and um
um if F or ch add something so but thank
you thank you for the opportunity that's
our
really um a reason
of we want you to
hear what we want thank you Jay do you
want to take us through the PowerPoint
so we've had a chance to have a
look
yes so I I was involved with the Mala
group um in uh probably mid 2021 and um
at the time uh they answered the call to
be part of the cultural games um group
where they uh showcase their traditional
games and some of their culture um at
the southern bedminton Hall um and so we
sort of built up a bit of relationship
and they asked about is there some
spaces in uh in the community where they
could meet cuz they were just currently
meeting um in a a garage in Glen Gary um
and so they were singing their songs and
and practicing their C culture uh um in
the middle of the night but sort of
being a bit noisy in in the region in
the area so we looking to find a space
and and we were fortunate enough to find
a space at the Queens par Tennis Club um
it just been done up and and we got that
opportunity um when we're well aware um
that it was at the most of three year
um sort of lease um uh to use that space
as the uh the construction of the museum
was um inevitable um and so um this
opportunity we we took and got some
Community well-being funding to to pay
for the lease um and in the kalu malua
group they moved in um and and from here
they've been able to attract um a lot
more uh of the tongen community right
across Southern and across
altero um the being a to form a pickle
ball Club um if no one's familiar with
pickle ball it's a mixture of table
tennis and Tennis um but a lot more uh
friendlier for the not as fast moving uh
individual um and there's no other
pickle ball Club in in Bago other than
one in Gore um so it's quite unique for
the for the for the town um they also
set up their own Community Hub as uh
Community Tennis Club as well um so
they're playing a lot of tennis in and
and uh pickle ball uh and then they're
also using the space just for coming
together
celebrating um and just a hub for the
Youth to come when they were working um
they'll be able to come in afterwards
meet um cheer stories just do all the
things that the young people do um and
so um I guess here we've
been in the process of looking for
another space um yeah we're just sort of
looking to hopefully um remain here here
at the tennis court until that
opportunity arises um yes so we're sort
of seeking the support from the council
to um let us stay in that space
until
um yeah until we do find another space
which um we are have been we are and
have been looking for for the last 3 or
months thanks Jay how often is the space
used by the
group from from what I
from my experiences every Friday
Saturday Sunday um a lot of um I I'll go
in there once or twice a month and and
visit the group um and a lot of their
night ship workers will will turn up 10
12:00 at night and they'll be there till
4:00 or 5: in the morning um just
catching up drinking cover and and
singing
songs
um yeah do you want to talk more about
that yeah for over the most of the men
on the photo is uh people from from
Tonga they they over here for the the
midw so my little the the little Hub is
mean a lot for them for us to make sure
they have a place to go to on the
weekend and um it's not only um Tongan
over there there F
mly over there as well so um yeah and
also at my we have a a Ry club and um we
support some of our boys they play for
the state we supported they they come to
my if they have a problem and uh some of
the young young boys they are high
perform sorry um performing over there
as well so uh yeah we support all our
boys our young boys uh at my as
well what's the value of the lease do
you
know I think it's just it's over just
over $11,000 a
year $3,000 $3,000 so that's across the
three years
yes thank
you I think the the the worldbe
Community Fund has been fund for three
years is $3,000 per year but I think
they fund um 9,000 something
oh so 3,000 a year yeah 3 do a year
right thank
you Council has any
questions Trish um thank you for your
presentation it's interesting can you
pull that microphone around Trish pardon
I didn't even know you existed so that's
something I learned today do you only
use it in the latter part of the night
the the the the Hub I'm just thinking is
there any way you could possibly arrange
to share with someone who doesn't some
you know um group that doesn't Ed at
that time of the
night do you use it during the day yes
so a lot of the time um the tennis
courts uh the table tennis sets are used
during the day um for the people that
don't work over or don't work during do
KN sh like that so it's getting used a
lot not just at night time but right
it's in the weekend um you can it's 100%
attendance rate in the weekends over
that night time cool thank you thank you
other
questions
um
um I suppose I'm curious from you as to
whether and you've indicated that you
understand that you do need to move and
that you're looking for somewhere um is
the reason that it suits you so well
because it's comparatively isolated for
your late night noise and so therefore
that's one of the attractions of it and
you would need somewhere
similar once you move is is that what
I'm hearing from you your instincts are
right yeah all I believe it's probably
good for the
Neighbors I was trying to find a tech
for way to say it um so but you've also
indicated that you understand that for
community's benefit that you
will be moving you your lease was only 3
years anyway so you're just wanting to
ensure that you're there till the end of
your
lease well there would be definitely an
extra bonus but I think just currently
at the moment in this immediate um time
until yeah we find it another space and
and I'm sure it won't be too long away
but um sort of over that Christmas
period um and it's sort of going to just
provide a bit of it's going to take away
a space in quite a celebratory time of
the year so the answer fire is there
until a suitable alternative venue is
found sounds that way um I don't think
we were evicting you before Christmas
it's not a good lock um no I appreciate
the fact that you have indicated that
you recognize that you're not there for
the long term and that you do need to
find something else so um
yeah thank you M M
Clark yeah Mine mine's a sort of
question as well I guess or reflection
um which is the where to from here
um so um thinking outside the square and
hoping that Caroline's not going to have
a meltdown in the background over there
um we've got another building in Queen
park that is used by the Blind
Association or whatever uh it's
reasonbly isolated
and I suspect not all that often used so
maybe that's an area of approach that
you might be able to look to um another
option would be rugby park and Peter's
going to kill me sitting beside me uh
but again Council has said in relation
to rugby park it needs to be a multiple
tenant facility it can't be exclusively
just for rugby so with that gives you
some options as well probably not too
much opposition from The Neighbors in
either those two
locations so just something to be
thinking about excellent question really
well understand the purpose of the
comment but that comes down to I think
what the submitter is saying is they're
open to all options but they need
something that is really available night
and day particularly across Friday
Saturday Sunday um and potentially not
in uh uh
in a residential
Zone other question
if there are none Vice and Fel Janine
and Jay thank you very much for U making
your submission um and for coming along
this afternoon and speaking with us we
appreciate
that thank you for your
submission
support So as a matter of pro cess uh
for the
hearing uh counselors the
recommendations are one that we receive
the report Queens Park reclassification
hearing two we accept the written
submissions received between September
30 and 3 November three we accept the
late submission from T mmer as a letter
of
support four we note the summary of
submissions and also the hearing
schedule as I said determination will be
made at the following meeting somebody
like to move those
recommendations move by Trish and Ria
it's open for
discussion there is none I'll put the
motion all in favor I against carried
Council as that brings us to the end of
uh the hearing so I'll formally close it
and just note that the decisions will be
made in the next meeting that the
recommendations that sit within the
staff report are merely there as as
thoughts starters you will be making
your own
determination uh I note that councilors
dermy and pottinger have arrived uh I'm
sorry but you'll be excluded from the
discussion the decision around because
you needed to be here throughout that
part of the the hearing all other parts
of the meeting good to go
and